ο κόσμος μέσα κάπό τα προβλήματα απου υπήρξαν της αλλάκες των δήμω αντιμετωπίζητω είναι θύμα
αμου επιτρεπετε έκφαση τς γράφειοκρατίας είναι από τα μεκατέρα προβλήματα που έχουμε δηλαδή δείχωρίς ι
κανέναν υπενιγμό τα έργατα οπίια πρέει να κάνουν σε ε εργασία με τον κετρικώ κράτος
είναι όλα καθηστερημένα εγώ θέλ απω ότι γραφιοκρατεία κάποιες φρος είναι ανοίκητη όσα εργα δεύ
εξαρτούμετόσοαπό τα κυρερνητι κατήπήματα προχωρούν πορεί πιο γρήγορα θέλω από ότι η γραφιοκρατία είνι είναι
έα μια γάκρι να την οποία δυστικώ στην κυπροτενικησαν και έχουμε πάρα πολύ δουριά προκιμένου
να γίνοντα από ότην μιανεισως τες διαδικασίες να υπάρχουν οη ελέγχει ν υπάρχει λογόδωση ια
διαφάνεια αλλ από την άλλη είναι όλη η αυτήα χρέτηκγραφιοκρατεία πρέπει να βρούμε να αντρώπο
να τξεπράσουν πως βλέπει ο αντρέας βύρας το ότι ο κόσμος όταν τους ζητά μια
θάρη είναι ουσιαστικά πελατιακές σχέσις δυναδή αυτός με ψήφησε αλρά μποράσου στίλει το μήνυμα αντρέα
εψήφισα ε θέλω ότων το χατήρη ο αντρέας πως το βλέπει γιατί σίγουρα στις σκέψεις
το αντρένι να οδούμε και μετά στη συζήήσης μας είναι μόνο το δημάρχιων καγτα ψέματα
αλλά ξεκινοται που το βασικό πως έτυχει πότ να ποια είσε ένα μήνυμα μπαστο κνητώσας
ογράφει αντρέα εναι έπρεπε να σε ψηφίσω εζή σας οτότων καια μου το γθησ να
επόο κάποια πραγμα σίγουρα τώρα να πούμε ότι είμαστε μάκριά που όλα αυτά ότι δεν
υπάρχουν οι προσωπικίές σχέσεις τα πρωτακά ζητήματα εμένα αρισκήμα ν μεν έχειο και απεριπεζω τον
κόσμό δεν έχει έτσι πράγμακανείς στην κύπρον ότι τελειώ νατελείος απόν από αυτά τα πράγματα
αά θέλ από ότι κάποιες τις θεσμικές αλλά κές που κάμαμε έχουν βοηθήσι τουλάχει στων
να υπάρχει ένας πούσουλασας επάρχει ενανόριον σετούν το πράγμα η πρώτη μο γίνηση που εκάμαμε
υπήρχαν τρει τη επιτροπές μια για τις φορολογίες να απόδημοδικούς στηβολούς που αρξιολόγαρανητήμα τα μείως
ισφορολογιών για ταεξώτηκα που έγραφε η προχονομία και και επιτροπές γεννικά